I look at the consumer spending and
income numbers we got today spending
down in come up that says to me that
we're actually saving the money that
we're earning here yeah it's actually
quite interesting because what we found
is that these gas prices actually
convinced more people to spend my money
on gas so they're not necessarily
spending a lot more money in retail or
restaurants right now which might come
later but they are seeing small lower
gas prices doing more weekend trips
drive there you know traffic into vegas
is up in the fourth quarter after
falling most of last year so right now
it seems that people are spending the
money a little bit and what the mostly
buying is more gasoline does that wind
up translating though into more buying
stay at the retail level because there's
a lag yeah historically what what
happens is there's initial boost into
gasoline purchases and then maybe about
a year later after sort of the drop in
prices begins historical data shows that
it's thought there's out and the
majority of the spending goes to retail
broad retail so if you look at gas price
basically started falling in july of
last year that would put the second half
about a year from then so that's when
we're expecting that you'll really see a
boost to retail as a whole the second
half of mecca this year is a spending
shift permanent i mean if we see another
rising gas prices save oil goes from 50
to 80 is it is it sticky the spending
that's usually not the case i mean the
one the one interesting thing is that
gas prices are supposed to stay low
relatively low through 2015 2016
basically not getting above three bucks
so if though if those gas prices stay at
that level we could see a substantial
sort of shift in consumer spending
towards more discretionary purchases
we're going out to eat more clothes
stuff like that but so far we really
haven't seen it even the CEOs of some of
the chains you think that would benefit
from this like family dollar said we
expect it but we haven't seen it yet it
comes with the leg and what's the total
number we're looking at and goldman says
125 billion dollar tax cut you look at
the retail level say the travel level
what are using well the without one or
25 billion could equate to about 750 to
like a thousand dollars savings per
family per year for that for this coming
year for for the year right now so it
doesn't seem like a lot but if you're
some of them in paycheck
paycheck or if you're you know you know
middle class mixture you know 100 bucks
a month basically it could go a long way
and what about savings you think we're
gonna save and not be stupid and save it
instead that's the thing we talked to in
the story we talked to consumers across
the country and then some were saying
I'm spending it now while it's low some
saying I'm not spending it all all right
Matt thanks so much i really appreciate
your joining me in matt townsend
bloomberg reporter